now the head of global aviation body
iata says he's confident the industry
will return to profitability in 2023.
aviation leaders are meeting in qatar to
discuss hiring and re-growth as airlines
recover from the kovid 19 pandemic it
plunged the sector into the worst
financial crisis in its history
qatar airways ceo akbar al-baqar says
he's cautiously optimistic
nobody can predict our industry for for
certain
ayat of course is
the the
leading
institution in our industry
they have a model to predict
but you know
it's only a prediction you don't know
what will happen
i
i am still
optimistic that
that things will continue for the
foreseeable future i also don't think
the oil price will stay
at this level forever
now the pandemic has wreaked havoc on
the global aviation industry losses are
estimated at more than 200 billion
dollars over two years and during that
time the air transport action group
reports that more than two million jobs
were cut now there's a scramble to hire
tens of thousands of employees but
security screenings are causing delays
the staff shortages have led to flight
cancellations especially in europe
despite the high numbers of people
wanting to travel the war in ukraine has
also doubled fuel prices leading to a
roughly 30 hike in flight prices well
joined now by osama bin javid who's at
the summit for us there's a lot to
discuss and a lot on the agenda
absolutely so so what we're hearing from
industry experts is a very optimistic
outlook to the recovery of the aviation
sector as you mentioned that it has been
one of the worst affected areas uh after
the pandemic but it is on the mend and
to discuss that uh we have with this uh
the regional vice president for eritrea
mr camilla thank you very much for being
with us thank you so a myriad of
challenges yet a very optimistic outlook
uh how do you square that and what gives
you so much confidence just just looking
at how well uh the industry performed
this year still started this year even
with a hiccup like the omicron the end
of last year
the resilience of the airline how nimble
they adjust
each airline adjusts its capacity and
what it needs you can see the numbers
just grow month over month uh looking at
their plans down the road i think we're
very optimistic that they will achieve
uh the numbers that you heard this
morning um
even with like the rising prices of oil
and stuff like that it's we're still
looking very optimistic so let's take a
look at the challenges that face the
aviation industry you're not completely
out of the pandemic there are still
restrictions there's very low
vaccination in africa you're looking at
higher fuel prices you're looking at a
slowing down of economies and this is
the peak sector of for the aviation
industry after the summer it's going to
slow down
again these numbers 83 recovery going
airlines going into break even or even
profit in 2023 uh feels like easier said
than done oh it's absolutely easier said
i mean let's not simplify this it's very
difficult you're absolutely right you
know there are still countries that are
restricted uh africa has very low
percentage of vaccines ukraine russia's
issue is hampering a lot and of course
the price of oil but we're still not
there yet
so so we're we're talking about 83 of
219 which was the highest year ever so
83 of 219 is still a high number but we
didn't say 100
because of these issues um yes airlines
are smart enough to not put all its
capacity back into the market
uh so so there's still 20 17
of that capacity not being used and of
course that reduces a lot of the the
operational cost or the fixed cost in
some cases so so they are managing their
resources more carefully
achieving the profit but don't forget
this is they're achieving a profit that
does not mean they're profitable they're
achieving a profit but they have two
years of losses to to to recap but there
are other factors here as well in in
addition to airlines capacity you're
talking about baggage handlers you're
talking about airport stuff at rising
costs um how is the aviation industry
going to cope because it has seen some
of the largest shrinking uh in the last
couple of years because of the pandemic
well the shrinking the shrinking is for
it's always taken into consideration so
if you don't need it you lower that
capacity and that's the shrinking that
you're talking about and did airlines
get it wrong
i think i think most of the airlines
specifically in this region calculated
their manpower requirements and their
resources very carefully and accurately
from what i can see
and i think the demonstration of how
they restarted again and they restarted
the bank at a faster rate than anybody
expected
and yet without the problems that we're
facing in europe and us so if you want
to think about how they manage their
resources i would say the gcc carriers
managed it beautifully i think what
every viewer wants to know is is are the
fair prices going to go down are they
going to see
better fares is the aviation industry
capable of providing the best services
for the lowest of costs yeah so so and
that's a valid question with with oil
prices this high with some of the
airports just increasing their charges
ridiculously overnight some of the
handling agents so on if it's a monopoly
um it's difficult to lower the price
it's difficult and don't forget the
airlines have taken loans onto their
books now which and that's a there's a
cost to that loan that has to be added
to its operational costs
so so with the prices i would say the
fuel being the the highest
contributor to the to the hike in prices
if the fuel remains this high then there
won't be any lowering of the prices but
airlines are nimble as soon as the fuel
starts dropping you will see them but
you see the airfares drop with it almost
immediately thank you very much for
speaking to us there you have it uh from
doha the view from kamil abadi the
regional vice president for the middle
east north africa region and and a
positive outlook bearing in mind there
is a number of difficulties that
continue uh to haunt not just the
airlines but airports and the overall
aviation industry and it might be a
while before that ticket to your
favorite destination gets any cheaper
thanks so much sun been driving there
for us in doha